se dire : dans la vie, quand on
veut aller au bout de nos idées,
quand on veut s'assurer qu'on
puisse faire parti de la
Montréal périclite des femmes
qui soufui sont
laissés pour compte, quand on
voit la situation qui n'est en
matière sens de la métropole
où on devenait... on estdevenaie
dans quelque élément que ce
soit, cesoit, cesoit, ce n'est t
à ce qu'on fait au premier
lorsque nous avons cettefonctiot
devant continuellement être à
l'affût et au-devant. Lorsque
j'ai parlé qu'il faut que
d'attente, j'espère que ça va
être le cas pour les quatre
pensée pour les candidats et les
candidates.
Le don de soi, choisir de se
présenter, franchir ce Rubicon
qui fait en sorte qu'on dit : je
veux faire parti de la solution.
Peu importe les pa
politiques. Mérites
félicitations. J'ane mainne main
d'applaudissements.
(applaudissements)
si je veux féliciter tous ceux
et celles qui ont été élues.
En politique, il y a des
gagnants et des perdants.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui sese
fois dans notre équipe.faire ma.
C'était ma 12e campagne
électorale. On n'en a vu de
Je reçois un appel en plus, ça
va bien.
que j'aime. Désolé.
Continuez. Je suis un peu dé
du faible taux de participation.
La démocratie municipale mérite
qu'on la protège
demeurent. Il y a s.
Il y a une réalité chez nos
jeunes. Il est essentiel est
important que tous ceux et
puissent assurer qu'il
y ait une plus grandees électioe
qu'elle soit. Ces pages auniveas
le milieu municipal.les 20 procs
de 70 % de population va seretr.
Il est primordial qu'on puisse
prendre notre place comme
gouvernement de proximité. Cela
cette force de frappe que
constitue notre population.
Et ça, ça se fait par les
Je veux remercier Francesco
Mielle comme directeur de
campagne qui a fait un travail
merci àt
travaille-pied et e-pied et e-pi
voyait comment Montréal pouvait
devenir beau, belle,e vue.
Je demande qu'on met la hargêtrr
tous les montréalaises et
montréalaises. Montréal en vaut
a besoin
d'aide et tous ceux et celles
qui se sont faites
faire parti de la solution.
Alors je demande s genss genss s
d'Ensemble Montréal, ils vont
jouer lee
l'opposition, mais il faut
transcender les partis
politiques il faut arrêter des e
j'ai vécus " quand on travaille
au niveau des idées il faut
passer par-dessus et Montréal
vaut la peine d'être vécu. tiont
ce qui touche la livraison des
services. Ce n'est pas toujours
de belles choses à voir. Laquese
out la gestiondes fonds publicse
que je vois présentement sur le
plan budgétaire et ce qui est
clair c'est que sinsemble panses
politiques qui se prenne lele dl
municipal, nous sommes une
administration, et notre rôle
c'est de s'assurer
choses à améliorer. Il faut
arrête
pragmati
J'ai vu des hommes et des femmes
exceptionnelles. J'ai vu deshomt
et j'ai vu des gens se donner
pour faipuisse retrouver sa fore
frappe. Cette campagne
ent
il y a du sang nouveau, non
seulement il y a un beau mixd'eu
l'occasion de mettre de l'avant
veux encore une fois remercier
tous ceux et celles qui ont
participé. Ce n'a pas été fait
sur un coin table. C'est un
travail de tout instant qui a
été fait et le fruit
d'expériences et de compétencess
gens sont écoeurés qu'on se tape
de nom. On a besoin d'un plan
d'action
d'être beaucoup plus rassembleur
et d'arrêter que le secteur
privé c'
développeurs c'est cela. Qu'on e
l'autre et qu'on aide du compte
continuetretretretretretretretre
les autres. On est plus fort que
ça. Le vivre ensemble ce n'est
pas seulement une vue de. Le vie
c'est un concept intrinsèque qui
nous définit et c'est l'ADN de
différentes communautés qui se
sentent délaissé il y a des gent
d'intolérance, de profilage,
quel qu'il soit et de s'assurer
qu'on travail va c
vigilance. Il faut arrêter de se
mettre la tête d et tous et tour
que l'on combatte ce sentiment
de sécurité.
j'aimerais féliciter Monsieur
Balarama Holness pour sa
Parfois
était et
présentés sous sa bannière. Jeeé
anglopho
esseulé il faut ramener les
gens, il faut ramener ces
auteurs de pont et s'assurer
le concept des deux solitudes et
résultat est clair. On n'en
suis vraiment content que
j'avançais des idées. J'étaise
tout l'étiquetage qu'on essaie
concentré sur les idées. Je suis
concentr
aussi et c'est ça qui est plus
importan
gens.
Certains seront cyniques avec
cette élection à cause du
de parti
passer par toute la gamme des
par cette voie citoyenne soit au
niveau de ce que vous faites
dans vos arrondisstion au nitios
arrondissements. Il y a
s
qu'il touchait peut-être pas
l'ensemble de la métropole mais
qui était nécessai
puisse travailler dans leur
milieu, dans leur êter de pensee
Montréal c'est juste le central.
Il faut
Il y a des laissés-pour-compte
sur le p
nous assurer qu'on puisse bien c
vous. Je suis très fier de vous.
Dans la vie c'est mieux d'avetst
je n'ai ni regrets ni remords et
quand on a l'impression d'alleré
et j'avais le goût à la suite de
ce que je voyais dpopulatipopule
valable pour qu'on puisse
ensemble retrouver
Montréal. J'espère que tous et
tous vous pensez que j'ai pu y
avoir contribué. Je veux vous
souhaiter une excellente soirée
et je vais vous dire avant t